[Música]
son considerados el mayor pueblo sin
estado del mundo a lo largo de la
historia los kurdos han sido perseguidos
por los países que rodean esas zonas
donde están asentados o por los países
en los que habitan muchos dicen por sus
ansias independentistas y sus ganas de
tener un territorio al que ellos puedan
Llamar nación la represión contra el
pueblo kurdo es tal vez uno de los
puntos en común que pueden tener en este
momento Turquía e Irán países vecinos
que están dispuestos a mitigar cualquier
alzamiento por parte de los kurdos y
también para recordarles que son una
minoría en su territorio todo lo
contrario ocurre en Irak en donde
cuentan con una región Autónoma tiene
libertad e incluso cuentan con una
economía que en cierta forma resulta
próspera los voy a poner entonces en
contexto los kurdos están esparcidos por
la zona de medio oriente ocupan amplias
zonas del este de Turquía el noreste de
Siria el norte y el este de Irak y buena
parte del Oeste de Irán también hay
algunas comunidades en territorio
armenio pero no tienen un estado es
decir no existe una República de
kurdistán no existe una República kurda
o estado kurdo
veamos algunos datos básicos para
entender Entonces de qué estamos
hablando el pueblo kurdo es étnicamente
heterogéneo se calcula que son entre 40
y 46 millones de personas alrededor del
mundo que hacen parte de los kurdos la
mayoría son musulmanes uníes aunque
también dentro de ellos hay algunas
minorías cristianas por ejemplo entre
otras pero ustedes se preguntarán Por
qué es esta noticia relevante ahora
porque es importante porque están
tomando relevancia en los últimos días
Pues precisamente por unos hechos
recientes días atrás las comunidades
kurdas en el norte de Siria han sido
blanco de bombardeos por parte de las
fuerzas armadas turcas todo esto en
represalia por el supuesto ataque
terrorista que ocurrió en Estambul el
pasado 13 de noviembre Aunque el partido
de los trabajadores del kurdistán Turco
de la zona del este de Turquía han
negado tener algo que ver con ese ataque
en la ciudad de Estambul y también
recientemente ustedes recordarán las
manifestaciones que han tenido lugar en
Irán la mayoría de ellas han tenido
lugar justamente en el ku iraní Pues el
gobierno de Teherán a reforzado la
presencia de los integrantes de la
guardia Revolucionaria en esa zona para
reprimir las marchas y también por ello
ha atacado algunas posiciones del
partido democrático del kurdistán que
también tiene presencia en Irak es un
poco confuso pero ya la vamos a analizar
aquí con nuestros invitados es por eso
que hoy en el debate de France 24 nos
preguntamos Por qué los kurdos vuelven a
quedar bajo fuego Qué hace la comunidad
internacional para poder garantizar sus
derechos y por qué los kurdos temen un
posible acercamiento que podría estarse
gestando entre el gobierno sirio y el
gobierno Turco que hace unos meses era
prácticamente imposible Y por qué los
hechos recientes tienen un alcance a
nivel regional y podrían tener alcance a
nivel internacional en el mediano plazo
para analizar este tema hemos invitado a
Gabriel clavijo él es politólogo e
internacionalista también es magister en
estudios políticos e internacionales me
acompaña aquí en el estudio de France 24
y desde la ciudad de Málaga En España se
conecta Julián Mateo se les analista en
políticas de seguridad y defensa se
conecta desde la ciudad de Málaga en el
sur de España ustedes nuestros
televidentes Recuerden que ustedes
también hacen parte de este debate
pueden dejar sus preguntas y sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales ya lo saben estamos en Twitter
en Facebook en instagram nos encuentran
como arroba el
debate_f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate f24 todo
junto todo pegado no olviden también ya
para terminar que todos nuestros
contenidos ya también están disponibles
en diferentes plataformas de podcast no
se encuentran en Apple podcast en
Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Julián en la ciudad de Málaga luego
vamos con nuestro invitado en el en el
estudio para conocer posiciones sobre
este tema y retomo una frase que dije en
la introducción Julián Bienvenido al
programa nuevamente los kurdos bajo
fuego esta vez fuego cruzado por parte
de los iraníes y los turcos que se puede
analizar de esta situación desde su
punto de vista
Pues mira en primer lugar también las
buenas noches y es verdad decías en la
introducción Es algo es algo complejo es
algo difuso y muchas veces cuando
pensamos en Oriente medio se nos viene a
la cabeza el conflicto tradicional árabe
en este caso israelíes con palestinos
Pero es verdad que tenemos al pueblo
kurdo en esa refriega también y en ese
conflicto constante y me apuntabas muy
bien la frase nuevamente porque ya no
nos encontramos solamente con un con un
conflicto regional sino que hay muchas
más aristas que lo pueden hacer un
conflicto en este sentido desde luego de
interés internacional los kurdos hasta
hasta hace bien poco 2019 aliados de
Estados Unidos han sido la punta de
lanza contradies contra el estado
islámico en la guerra que se ha Librado
para expulsarlos de la zona y además en
este sentido la propia el propio ataque
de Turquía no es un elemento nuevo no
hay que desdeñar en este sentido de que
de 2016 ya se habían lanzado tres
ofensivas contra territorio creando una
franja una franja de seguridad en la
última que fue la única en la que hubo
disputa congresa contra soldados en este
caso sirios fue mediada por Rusia y yo
creo que eso es una cosa muy
significativa del momento actual que
están bien medir como el tradicional
contrapeso mediador de la zona que era
Rusia en la situación que tienen Ucrania
como como va a actuar en este momento
pasó ahora a darle la bienvenida a
Gabriel aquí en el estudio de France 24
Gabriel Gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
el programa y también la misma pregunta
como Punto de partida los cursos bajo
fuego otra vez que se puede analizar
pero esta vez de pronto ve uno dos
países muy importantes en la región
atacando a por sus diferentes motivos a
esta minoría bueno es una nueva fase del
conflicto que ya lleva larga Data es un
conflicto que no es nuevo es un
conflicto Antiguo y es una nueva es el
recauche de unas nuevas exi de unas
nuevas dinámicas internacionales vemos
Que Irán vemos Que intereses de Turquía
vemos Que Siria también está metida
entonces vemos una nueva dinámica dentro
de unos actores que están cobrando
potencia que están cobrando impacto
dentro de la región y que buscan
asegurar sus poderes dentro de la región
si nosotros vemos a Irán como un eje de
poder de peso en medio oriente igual que
Turquía que también está buscando bajo
el gobierno de erdogan tener una
posición muy fuerte dentro de la región
entonces Creo que este late motive del
pueblo kurdo es perfecto para que juegue
con los intereses regionales de estas
potencias medias que están en ascenso
dentro de medio oriente a ver para
entender un poco los hechos estos
bombardeos por parte de Turquía y de
Irán en las diferentes regiones donde
hay población kurda hay que entender
para ponernos en contexto Gabriel
mmm porque Turquía Siria e Irán no
quieren comprometerse con esa integridad
territorial del pueblo Turco un anhelo
de un estado donde puedan entrar todos
los los integrantes de este pueblo kurdo
Pues bueno desde el tratado de stef en
1920 cuando se le dio el reconocimiento
internacional al pueblo kurdo que no fue
ratificado por Ninguno de los firmantes
después y en lausana que fue la
descomposición y la destrucción casi del
imperio otomano ahí sí hubo
reconocimiento internacional
partimos de que se borró al pueblo kurdo
del ámbito y del concierto internacional
esto genera una serie de
expectativas de exigencias de demandas
de rencores históricos por parte del
cuerpo pueblo kurdo y por parte de los
países en donde quedó dispersa toda esta
población una serie de represiones en
mayor o en menor medida muy sangrientas
algunas otras han pasado por debajo de
la cuerda u otras simplemente han sido
invisibilizar al pueblo kurdo sin
embargo para los países no les conviene
perder territorio porque sería la la
creación de un nuevo estado un nuevo
actor internacional y no les convendría
tampoco perder o generar la posibilidad
para un nuevo actor internacional que
por supuesto va a tener el respaldo de
toda la comunidad internacional por mera
solidaridad y por el sufrimiento del
pueblo curvo históricamente qué va a ser
no va a ser juego a sus intereses
regionales entonces creo que miran ni
Turquía están interesados de pronto dirá
que es un caso aparte como tú bien
dijiste tiene cierto reconocimiento el
pueblo kurdo tiene un estatus de
autonomía y efectivamente tiene un grado
de prosperidad económica y social mucho
mejor que
hermanos que están en los otros lados de
la frontera claro Vámonos ahora al
presente Julián hablar de lo que ha
desencadenado estos bombardeos recientes
en la zona del norte de siriablo
exactamente ese ataque terrorista que
mencionaba yo en la ciudad de Estambul
este ataque desde su análisis qué tanto
Es verdaderamente un ataque provocado
en señal de protesta contra el gobierno
del presidente erdogan o esto que tanto
tiene componente político para erdogar
justificar esta operación militar en un
momento en el que él está en campaña
porque hay elecciones presidenciales en
Turquía el año entrante
efectivamente Ese es el kit de la
cuestión para de los dos de los dos
actores que tenemos en la situación
actual y me derivo un poco en Irán por
descontado todos sabemos por las
circunstancias actuales que tienen por
lo tanto es una pantalla perfecta y con
respecto a la segunda parte de Turquía
en mayo del 23 tenemos elecciones por lo
tanto efectivamente parece ya una
precampaña a todas luces Porque desde el
punto de vista de la investigación y de
la justificación pero sobre todo también
de la motivación no tiene sentido es
decir que los kurdos cometieran el
atentado del 13 de noviembre porque no
está dentro de ningún tipo de campaña ni
de respuesta que que lo justifique y sin
embargo en este sentido pues es una
excusa perfecta que que blande en este
caso erdogan pues para el inicio de esta
campaña que como comentábamos no es
solamente en ese sentido un acto más de
la propia precampaña sino que a mi
juicio y lo comentaba antes el compañero
de cara establecer posiciones de
jerarquía como potencias medias en la
zona insisto a lo que decía al principio
y Turquía lleva tiempo intentando ser
una potencia en este caso concreta en la
en la zona de con influencia regional no
se puede escapar desde luego la
situación de Rusia que en ese sentido
tiene y ha tenido una presencia
importantísima en Siria la tiene con
bases navales con salidas al
Mediterráneo y esa debilidad de Rusia yo
creo que está siendo utilizada por
Turquía a modo de medida para ver en qué
situación están las espadas en este
sentido con respecto al equilibrio de
fuerzas
en Gabriel aquí en el estudio de France
24cito unas palabras de El señor sala
eldine amud un ciudadano kurdo de 55
años en la franja de frontera entre
Siria y Turquía él dice somos Víctimas
de una erradicación Aquí hay un intento
por eliminar del mapa a los kurdos como
en el pasado sucedió tal vez con los
armenios por ejemplo bueno hablar de un
Exterminio un genocidio como el del
pueblo armenio que fue terrible fue
horroroso por parte del pueblo Turco que
aún no lo reconoce sí por demás pues
sería un poco avesado hablar de eso
pienso más bien que a Turquía le
interesa es acabar con dos vertientes
sobre todo con una boda centrarme en una
en el partido kurdo de los trabajadores
el pkk el pkka es un partido que está
funcionando desde hace 40 años que ha
tenido una reivindicación de en su
inicio de autonomía total del Estado
Turco y de la creación del kurdistán
más recientemente ha moderado un poco su
posición y ahora Busca un régimen
autonómico dentro de él estado Turco
algo muy parecido a lo que sucede en
Irak pero que siempre ha tenido un
componente muy fuerte de ataques
terroristas un componente muy fuerte de
ataque a la población turca
una una tradición de
atentados terroristas básicamente son
los enemigos número uno del gobierno de
erdogan y por otra parte
los los atentados del reciente noviembre
13 en Estambul
implican otro actor nuevo dentro de la
ecuación y es el ipg que son las
milicias de defensa popular del pueblo
kurdo pero en Siria o sea los kurdos
sirios no los kurdos
en Turquía sino los kurdos sirios en esa
medida
erdogan ha sido muy agresivo y a
bombardeado estos pueblos en Siria lo
cual puede generar una desestabilización
total del sistema y sumemoslo también al
asesinato por parte de la guardia de la
moral del régimen iraní de la chica
kurda de 16 años más allá
y eso ha generado también
encresparlos los los ánimos dentro de la
población kurda en Irán entonces vemos
que hay tres factores tres vertientes
que están caldeando los ánimos en
Turquía en Siria y en Irán y Turquía
está empezando a pescar en río revuelto
ahí Entonces no creo que busque
exterminar al pueblo kurdo además son 40
millones de personas 19 millones en
Turquía pues es la más grande de Turquía
es La minoría más grande en el medio
oriente No creo que se piense exterminar
como tal Pero si hay un interés muy
fuerte en acabar toda resistencia
política y militar que presenta esta
minoría eso en cuanto al lado Turco pasó
a preguntarle entonces a Julia por el
lado iraní que ya también le va a
preguntar por ese tema Gabriel allí
También si están gestando problemas en
esa Región del Oeste de Irán la guardia
Revolucionaria la han desplegado allí
Para mitigar el impacto de las protestas
y también ha habido ataques muy fuertes
ataques incluso del otro lado de la
frontera en territorio iraquí Cómo es el
estatus de los kurdos dentro de la
República islámica de Irán han sido
blanco de ataques a lo largo de la
historia o Esto es algo nuevo para esta
minoría en ese país
en realidad yo creo que para el pueblo
kurdo como como es mía como como como
contingente en este sentido en los
ataques que han subido en cada uno de
los países en los que están asentados No
son nuevos y lo que se refería al
principio en este sentido Es verdad que
se reconocimiento no como como entidad
nunca ha ido ligado a un reconocimiento
territorial por lo tanto Siempre han
tenido ese estatus entendamos en la
palabra de no y de huéspedes no no no
deseados en los países en los que en los
que Residen en los que se habitan que
además no dejan de ser un ente
supranacional y en y en concreto en Irán
Pues sí puede ser con respecto a la zona
con respecto al gobierno
del Estado receptor el país en el que
tengan la dificultad mayor en este
sentido y no solamente
estos ataques y ese despliegue de
guardias Revolucionaria no es solamente
un intento por en ese sentido de
erradicar desde el punto de vista de las
esperanzas futuras sino dar un aviso en
el caso de que no se va a tolerar Pues
un ejemplo como lo que se ha instalado
en este sentido en el kurdistán ir aquí
porque es verdad que tanto el pkk como
los kuros en conjunto ya no están en esa
línea de Independencia total de estado
totalmente independientes sino que
buscan ese germen autonómico que ha
entrado en Irak y que yo creo que en
este sentido los gobiernos iraní y
turcos temen que se propague Porque
además no sería en este caso una
reivindicación tan criticable como puede
ser la creación de un estado
independiente e intentan que ese germen
de cierta independencia de cierta
autonomía no no germine en sus
territorios Gabriel su opinión sobre el
caso iraní
Yo estoy de acuerdo con mi colega en
España creo que esto va a generar
ciertas no ciertas muchas Preocupaciones
en el gobierno de Irán en el gobierno de
Turquía creo que la posición del
gobierno iraní también temen que las
manifestaciones populares se conviertan
en un problema que se le salga de la
mano y que el régimen no pueda controlar
en este momento
se está viendo la gran simpatía que
tiene el mundo entero por la causa de
esta chica la gran simpatía que tiene
toda la población todos los medios
internacionales frente a la causa curda
iraní a pesar de que es un régimen Es un
régimen autócrata y es una dictadura
básicamente tiene implicaciones dentro
de la gobernanza Y gobernabilidad
eso genera También muchas
cuestionamientos a nivel internacional
si bien no les importa mucho a los
ayatolas que dirá la presa internacional
si tiene un componente de peso además
Hay cosas hay factores y hay síntomas
que del malestar que vive el gobierno
iraní nomás citamos en el mundial de
fútbol hoy en Irak en Perdón en Qatar
la simpatía que ha tenido las barras
iraníes y la censura que han tenido las
barras iraníes y las amenazas que han
habido frente a las familias de los
jugadores de fútbol que han sentado su
posición de simpatía con la causa curva
de represalias con sus familias en Irán
eso puede generar eso es un síntoma de
El gran malestar que genera para el
régimen de Irán estas manifestaciones
populares que se están dando leyendo
algunos análisis de diferentes autores
internacionales se encuentra uno con
algunos de ellos que coinciden en decir
que se están empezando a reunir ciertos
factores muy puntuales en el kurdistán
iraní como para estar pensando en que se
está gestando allí una especie de
rebelión de revolución allí regional que
pues no se sabe si pueda trascender o no
si sigue la presencia de la de la
guardia Revolucionaria Jim mitigando
todas estas el impacto de las de las
manifestaciones ciudadanas pero que hay
unos componentes muy dicientes que que
hacen pensar que no es un levantamiento
común y corriente como puede haber como
hemos visto en años anteriores en las
calles de otras ciudades iraníes quiero
escalar este tema un poco a la escena
internacional y aquí hay un punto
importante que quiero analizar y es la
relación que tienen los kurdos con
Estados Unidos y que han tenido los
kurdos con la otan Y en este momento
estados unidos no ha dicho absolutamente
nada ni la comunidad internacional ha
dicho absolutamente nada por estos
bombardeos que Está realizando Turquía
en el norte de Siria y esta represión en
el oeste de Irán voy a hacer la ronda la
inversa entonces continuó con Julián en
la ciudad de Málaga aquí usted puede
decir de esta relación y el silencio de
Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea cuando
en los últimos años apoyaron a los pech
Mega
Pues mira es muy significativo y además
es otra Arista de conflicto porque
efectivamente visitando a las propias
milicias ipg Estados Unidos ha sido el
principal Aliado en este caso del pueblo
kurdo y ya había un abastecimiento una
formación y un combate conjunto de las
ipg con los soldados estadounidenses
desplegados en la zona con contra el
daes contra el estado islámico y
efectivamente comentabas que es el
Aliado principal que había dicho la otan
pero es que no se nos tiene que olvidar
que tu tía también eso tan es decir nos
encontramos con una con una
contraposición de dos aliados en el seno
de la alianza atlántica Turquía
evidentemente no tiene el peso que
Estados Unidos Pero sí tiene un peso muy
Regional de contrapunto y de puerta de
entrada hacia dentro de la alianza
atlántica es más ahí en este sentido
misiones con establecimiento de
contingentes en territorio Turco dentro
de la alianza atlántica de protección de
fronteras por lo tanto de ahí de de la
forma de unificar en una respuesta me
parece que viene el hecho de que no
tengamos todavía pues es un comunicado
una comunicación que desde luego no se
puede parecer mucho lo que sería una
crítica porque nos encontramos con eso
con que tenemos dos actores antagónicos
con respecto a los intereses en el
conflicto pero que sin embargo son
socios dentro de la alianza atlántica
claro y por este lado Gabriel su opinión
Bueno yo voy a tomar desde el punto de
vista de la Unión Europea Ya que ni
colega lo ha tomado desde el punto de
vista de la otan y es Turquía es
supremamente importante para la Unión
Europea la posición geográfica de
Turquía la hace estratégica para los
intereses de la Unión Europea en el
medio oriente y sobre todo en cuestiones
de migración Turquía puede funcionar
como un estado tapón que permite que las
migraciones masivas de Estados de Asia
central y de estados del medio oriente
sean contenidas dentro de las fronteras
turcas si bien el régimen de
cordogan No no ha presentado la misma
cercanía tradicional que ha tenido
Turquía con Europa ha habido una
distanciamiento un poco más evidente con
bajo el gobierno de erdogan Turquía
sigue siendo una pieza clave y
fundamental de la Unión Europea
obviamente no ha entrado a la Unión
Europea por ciertos temores obviamente
por su religión hay que decirlo son
musulmanes el primer estado musulmán en
la Unión Europea pues es difícil que
pase pero
sí es muy importante tener a Turquía
dentro de la Unión Europea en los
jugando a los intereses de la Unión
Europea y creo que eso hace también
responde un poco al silencio que ha
tenido la Unión Europea o la prudencia
para condenar los actos de de agresión
evidente que tiene el régimen de erdogan
frente al pueblo Turco importante ese
punto además que también tenemos que
hablar de otra coyuntura importante la
crisis energética que está viviendo
Europa en este momento y que muchos de
los gasoductos que van a traer gas desde
azerbaiyán o desde otros puntos de Asa
central van a pasar por territorio Turco
entonces a Bruselas le conviene tener
contento a ankara y tener contento a
erdogan y también por otro factor y otro
factor importante que pongo sobre la
mesa Rusia el conflicto con Ucrania
Turquía ha sido el país mediador y es el
que ha estado tratando de poner a
conversar aquí a Moscú y a incluso ha
puesto su territorio a disposición para
esta mesa de diálogo pero aquí Rusia
empieza a jugar un papel distinto con
Turquía porque ya no le parece muy
agradable verlo haciendo operaciones
militares Julián en el norte de Siria
porque aquí va contra sus intereses aquí
chocan Moscú y ankara
efectivamente Y además en los últimos
años tanto Moscú como ankara han tenido
una una relación de de continuos
enfrentamientos que luego han tenido en
momentos en los que se ha rebajado la
tensión Pero hay una cosa indispensable
como como bien comentabas Y es que el
principal Aliado de pasar al azar del
principal Aliado del gobierno en este
sentido sirio es Rusia por lo tanto
efectivamente la influencia que Rusia
tiene ha tenido y que plantea tener con
respecto a Siria es totalmente amenazada
desde el punto de vista que Turquía
quiero ocupar parte en el reparto de esa
plaza por eso en ese principio lo que en
un momento podía aparecer buenas maneras
o ese momento de fraternal en el sentido
de actuar mediante el punto de la
mediación en el momento en que Rusia
percibe o ve incluso la posibilidad como
como se plantea y que no y que no es
desdeñable de una operación terrestre en
Turquía hace que en ese sentido Ya vea
la intención desde desde el punto de
vista y Y en este caso va a ser también
una vara de medida para Rusia es decir
tiene un conflicto abierto en Ucrania
que desde luego no le va bien que le ha
supuesto un menoscabo no solamente a su
capacidad militar sino a eso que se
conoce en este sentido no como la
persuasión es decir en la teoría del
espectro de la Guerra el momento de
evitar la guerra es el temor del enemigo
a que en este caso me supere o a no ser
capaz de superarlo evidentemente esa
teoría del espectro de la guerra la está
perdiendo en Ucrania y hay que ver sin
ese sentido Turquía es capaz de ir un
poco más allá y seguir midiendo la
capacidad de respuesta diplomática en un
primer momento y luego ya veremos más
adelante de Rusia en la zona ya lo
veremos efectivamente Julián Gabriel por
este lado su opinión sobre el papel de
Rusia aquí importante actor en este en
este conflicto o en esta situación Bueno
yo creo que el papel de Rusia en este
momento se ha visto un poco opacado
Rusia está distraída en otros asuntos
está está más metida dentro del problema
ucraniano en este momento sin embargo
Rusia tiene
sendos intereses en la región estoy
hablando Por ejemplo de los gasoductos
que tiene
la posibilidad de el comercio de gas
natural con el bloque de la Unión
Europea es fundamental Europa también
tiene intereses muy grandes para los
recursos rusos Y estos pasan por el
norte de Siria y por toda Turquía
entonces creo que Rusia en este momento
está un poco distraída con el asunto de
los ucranianos de Ucrania sin embargo
creo que Rusia
puede tener su papel de mediador y de
buen buen facilitador buen amigo o buen
gestor de los intereses para
estabilización regional sin embargo los
ataques de Turquía a la población sirio
kurda teniendo en cuenta que el régimen
de bachara las ades claramente un Aliado
fundamental para Vladimir Putin puede
alterar esta posición rusa y puede
fortalecerla o puede Por decirlo de
alguna manera hacerla más dura frente a
Turquía y eso genera mucho más
inestabilidad porque Entonces estaría
dándole la razón a la Unión Europea para
fortalecer su posición frente a Rusia
sumado a la posición que tiene con
Ucrania Entonces es la Tormenta perfecta
para la escalada de un posible conflicto
región que hay de esas de esos
comentarios Gabriel que han dicho desde
el gobierno Turco lo ha dicho Incluso el
presidente erdogan en algunas
entrevistas que estaría dispuesto a
conversar con el presidente de Siria
bachara lassad Pese a que la relación ha
estado rota entre los dos países desde
el comienzo de la guerra en Siria Ahora
parece que al tener un enemigo en común
serían estas fuerzas del ipg podría
llegar a un punto de por lo menos un
acercamiento lo veo usted factible
posible bueno el enemigo de mi amigo el
enemigo de mi enemigo es mi amigo
partamos de ese principio podría pasar
bajo esa óptica sin embargo creo que
está demasiado lejos erdogan de Putin sí
los intereses de erdogan de configurarse
como una potencia media regional van en
contra vía directa con los intereses de
Putin de mantener el control regional
dentro de Asia central y sobre todo
también porque le conviene tener a los
vecinos musulmanes de Asia central muy
tranquilos para sus intereses en el
cáucaso sí recordemos que
el caucaso es una región estratégica por
su cercanía y por sus límites con
Ucrania Entonces es un delicadísimo
juego de ajedrez que Putin tiene que
mantener lo más estable posible
sin ir a alterar a erdogan También es
importante tener en cuenta y mencionar
el carácter de erdogan erdogan es una
persona supremamente
irascible y autoritaria entonces no es
tan indescifrable o casi que desconocido
en su forma de ser como Donald Trump que
a veces tenía unas salidas en falso que
dejaban al mundo desconcertado sin
embargo
erdogan es una persona que hay que
mantener tranquila porque su
personalidad es un poco fuerte difícil
vamos a preguntarle a en la ciudad de
Málaga por por esta posible reunión
entre edogan y bachara lassad o ese
acercamiento Damasco ankara y Gabriel
mencionaba esa necesidad de mantener la
presencia en la región y mantenerse como
un actor sólido en la región pero es que
también en esa región a los iraníes les
importa también mostrarse fuertes y
mostrarse estables entonces sumo también
a Irán en ese en ese conflicto en ese en
ese escenario y en ese posible encuentro
yo partiría en este caso de en dos
conceptos principales es decir el hecho
en sí del de la reunión de la
posibilidad de que sé de que se realice
esa reunión no es nada no es nada
descartable porque en este caso antes de
2011 el tanto las la República decidía
en este caso como como Turquía eran eran
aliados y socios comerciales muy
importantes y además con amistades con
afinidades personales por lo tanto el
hecho en sí de que se produzca esa
reunión además enmarcado en esa campaña
publicitaria en este sentido
vinculadas a las elecciones turcas no es
descartable que esa reunión como tal
tenga tenga avisos de fructificar que de
esa reunión salgan acuerdos concretos
que de esa reunión se rebaja la tensión
creo que es prácticamente imposible
primero porque las posiciones en este
sentido de Turquía y de y de Siria son
antagónicas con independencia en este
caso del odio como uno del inconveniente
común que ambos tienen con los con Los
kurdos pero las posiciones entre ambos
países son antagónicas y además en este
sentido no hay que olvidar que todavía a
día de hoy Turquía plantea un apoyo poco
disimulado de las fuerzas opositoras
armadas en Siria y luego además en este
sentido Pues hay otro factor importante
y es la influencia que tiene Rusia con
pasar a las app Y en este sentido como
como hemos comentado el colega con
anterioridad a Rusia no le interesa
perder en este sentido la esa capacidad
primero de influencia sobre Damasco Y en
segundo lugar de influencia regional por
lo tanto también parece difícil que
Rusia permita que ese encuentro
fructifique y dos preguntas rápidas
Julián para hacer la ronda la inversa 1
Hay posibilidades de un ataque terrestre
a gran escala por parte de las fuerzas
turcas en el territorio sirio como lo ha
dicho el presidente erdogan y dos estos
ataques en Siria qué tanto le dan la
sartén por el mango a Turquía para
entorpecerle el camino a la Unión
Europea y a la otan me refiero a la al
ingreso de Suecia y Finlandia
Pues mira respondiendo de forma muy
breve Y en este sentido empiezo por la
segunda No creo que Turquía en este caso
busque un enfrentamiento directo o en
este sentido una contraposición concreta
y antagónica con sus socios de la otan
porque al final son sus socios por lo
tanto en este sentido creo que va a
llevar una presión de una forma muy
limitada y con respecto a la posibilidad
del ataque terrestre desde el punto de
vista estratégico desde el punto de
vista de la razón militar todo hace
pensar que no es posible que no se va a
realizar pero ese ese esa forma
impulsiva que decía el compañero de
erdogan que yo me atrevería a elevarlo a
avemente él hace una comparativa no con
esa reacción que podía tener Donald
Trump pero Donald Trump tiene un sistema
de contrapesos el Powerball en que
Estados Unidos que lo frenaba erdogan no
tiene ese contrapeso en su gobierno su
gobierno democrático pero muy presencia
muy autoritario en ese sentido por lo
tanto lo que la razón indica que no es
posible en manos de erdogan no es
descartable voy a dejar una pregunta
para la conclusión ya me queda un par de
minutos para finalizar el programa hemos
analizado este tema desde el lado Turco
desde el lado sirio desde el lado de los
iraníes o tan Unión Europea a todas
estas que pueden hacer los cultos para
toda esta situación qué van a hacer
Quién los va a ayudar Cómo se van a
defender o cómo van a responder Gabriel
bueno los kurdos Creo que van a ser lo
que han hecho durante 40 años Lo
principal es resistir como sociedad es
la principal arma que ellos tienen y lo
han hecho efectivamente Y muy
exitosamente resistir como nación dentro
de sus intereses su historia sus
componentes que los unen como pueblo han
sido muy exitosos si no se han dejado
disgregar 40 millones de personas en
varios países
conservan su idea de nación y su deseo
de construirse como un estado eso es que
van a hacer lo segundo la comunidad
internacional
Va a continuar pienso que en algunos
momentos dando sus posiciones condenando
los actos o condenando o Llamando a La
Paz o Llamando al entendimiento de las
de las Naciones no creo que haya una
intervención de defensa explícita para
el pueblo kurdo por ninguna de las
potencias como hemos visto acá a la
Unión Europea no le interesa ni a la
otan tampoco desplegar fuerzas teniendo
en cuenta que Turquía también está
metida ahí obviamente no no no van a ir
en contra de los intereses de sus
propios miembros ni tampoco de los
intereses de un socio estratégico dentro
de la región como es Turquía claro otros
factores teniendo en cuenta que erdogan
puntual por favor que se me acaba el
tiempo teniendo en cuenta que erdogan la
personalidad sí que tiene tan violenta
en ciertas formas pues van a tener que
dejar un poco al lado al pueblo Turco
Julián su rápidamente por favor
pues Efectivamente es muy similar es
decir se puede esperar cualquier cosa
insisto la razón indicaría que la
escalada violenta no debe ir a más pero
en manos de quién estamos y
especialmente de los líderes tanto de
Turquía como de Irán
nos podemos esperar cualquier cosa Bueno
pues a Juliana Gabriel les agradezco
mucho por haber estado con nosotros en
el programa es todo por hoy En nombre
del equipo técnico Les agradecemos la
sintonía la producción del programa
estuvo a cargo de Keila maestre y la
producción de invitados a cargo de Lina
Guzmán y Samuel Salgado gracias por su
sintonía sigan con France 24
[Música]